(audience cheering)
- Green too!
I was like, so green's my favorite color.
- Well, good.
- Yeah, my favorite color to wear is red.
What's your favorite color to wear?
- Blue.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- But I'm a jewel tone girl.
- I'm a jewel tone girl.
- I go jewel tone.
- Yes.
- All the pastels, I love
the idea of a pastel.
- I don't, I look dead.
- Not good.
- Yeah.
- Not good for me.
- I look dead, no matter how
much makeup you put on me.
- Christmas, good, Easter, eh.
- [Kelly] Yeah I don't do
Easter like that, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm glad we solved this.
- We did.
- Crisis averted for the day.
- [Laura] I know.
- So you grew up in New York?
- I did.
- It's such a great music scene there.
- It is.
- I've seen so many amazing shows,
be it like a small little club,
or a huge show at like the arena,
so what's like some of your best memories,
like music, where would you go?
- Well, we would go to the Garden.
When I was growing up, it
would be Madison Square Garden.
I saw the Beach Boys there.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I took my sister to
a Duran Duran concert
and I saw Stevie Wonder there as well.
- You saw Stevie Wonder?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I've never seen Stevie Wonder.
- Well, listen, I have
to say there's one thing
I wanna tell you.
Because you did a song on the
"Love Actually" soundtrack--
- Yes.
- Which is so beautiful, by the way.
- "Trouble With Love" is--
- It's a beautiful song.
- Oh, thank you.
Forget the song, I love the movie.
(laughs)
- But I almost met you on the red carpet.
- What?
- For the premiere.
We were there, you were
four people to the right.
And I couldn't get to you.
And it drove me crazy.
- What!
You were trying to get to me?
- I was and here's why, here's why,
because I had this amazing
friend named Stanley DeSantis.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Who was in a TV show called
"Tales the City" with me.
- Yeah.
- We watched you every
week on "American Idol".
- What!
- We rooted for you
from the very beginning.
- What is happening?
(audience cheers)
Are you serious?
- We would call each other.
He lived in Los Angeles,
I lived in New York.
It was like our thing was to watch you.
And you did a 40s song at one point.
- That's my favorite one!
- And we were like, "look at her go!"
Girl got range.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, we were all over it.
And he's no longer with
us, my friend Stanley.
But every time I see you, I think of him.
- [Kelly] Ah, we love Stanley.
- And so it's...
(audience clapping)
- I can't even believe-
- So you mean more than you ever knew.
- That is the craziest
thing ever and so sweet.
But by the way, I
remember that red carpet.
- Yeah, it was intense wasn't it?
- It was.
And I had to go after Keira Knightley.
- Oh yeah.
(laughs)
- And it's like red carpets
were still fairly new to me.
- I was thinking it must have
been one of your first ones.
- And she was like full on like a model.
- [Laura] Oh yeah.
- 'Cause she was just posing.
- The girls know how to do it, I don't.
- I looked like a girl scout.
- I know you're like, "hi!"
- Right after Keira
Knightley, like I was like,
I tried so hard.
And then I saw her like
posing and I was like, oh.
I was like, I was trying.
I felt so uncomfortable 'cause
I'm never around actors.
I'm always around musicians.
- Sure, but I remember leaning back
and looking and seeing you.
- What!
- Like four people down
and I could never get
to you and I was so...
So here we are, 20 years later.
- You would've made feel so good.
(audience clapping)
That's amazing.
I have to say this though.
So your friends are different from mine
because you shared this photo
of you and Brooke Shields as girls.
Y'all knew each other as young kids?
- Isn't that funny?
Isn't that funny?
We grew up together.
- What?
- Isn't that wild?
- Yes.
- I know we were in grade school together
and we were very close
for a period of time.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And this was on a vacation.
We went to Howe Caverns
together in upstate New York.
- I remember when that picture was taken.
And we have a very sweet friendship
because we've known each
other our entire lives.
We're not in contact all the time
but when we run into
each other occasionally
it's always so nice.
'Cause we knew each other as--
- I have those friends that you've known
since you were a kid.
- As little children.
I remember the stuffed animals on her bed.
She remembers parents
who are no longer alive.
We have a deep connection that way.
- That's so cool to have that kind of,
especially with you both
being in the limelight
and just being able to
talk about that as well.
- Yeah, absolutely.
No, that comes in very handy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You have to have the safe people.
- I just thought that was so random.
I was like, wait, what?
- [Laura] Isn't that wild?
- Yes.
- [Laura] I know.
- I was like, your childhood
was different than mine.
- Well I didn't go to
school with a dozen celebs.
- I know, I was like,
wow, that's so random.
But your son is about that
age now, so how's he doing?
What's he into?
- He's good, sports.
- Sports?
- Sports, sports, sports, sports, sports.
- Sports ball.
- Anything with a ball that you run.
- [Kelly] My daughter's like that.
- Football, basketball,
Chicago Bulls, Brooklyn Nets.
The whole thing.
- That's amazing, my
daughter's really into sports,
my son is into like Legos.
- [Laura] Oh yes, yeah, isn't that fun?
- Anything built, he
loves to build anything.
- I like the Legos.
- [Kelly] I know, but I love it.
- Oh my God, I love it too,
but there's so many of them.
- [Kelly] I know, but I love it.
- Oh my God, and then
you gotta organize them
and the whole thing.
- Because you can check out
and the directions are so,
It's kind of therapeutic
- I love the directions.
- I feel like people
that put those directions
like together for Legos
should do that for furniture,
whoever does that.
'Cause they're way better
at it than the other people.
- But I want like Lego socks
so that when I step on them, I don't,
(audience laughs)
I want like a special sock.
(audience claps)
- So I'm a disciplinary.
So like I'm that mom.
So like we don't have many
Legos hanging out on the floor.
- You see, I would--
- [Kelly] I throw them away
- Come to my house.
Can you come help me out?
- I'm this mom.
I literally don't care if I bought it.
I will be like, if it's not gone
by the time I walk back through this room,
and they know, it'll go
directly in the trash.
- [Laura] Good for you.
- Yeah, 'cause I am not a broken record.
I don't like repeating myself constantly.
- Well and they're at that age now.
- I don't know how many times
to tell you to pick that up.
So I'm just gonna throw it away.
- You need to come to my house.
(audience cheers)
- That was a clip from
her Netflix series "Ozark".
It's amazing!
But we have a tradition around here
where a Bundt cake a pan is
passed from person to person
on the staff and crew each week.
And basically you pass the pan
to someone who you appreciate
and you wanna thank
but you have to do it as
a surprise or a prank.
I prefer prank.
By saying like, "you've been bunted."
So when the person you're
bunting, they least expect it.
So you kind of get freaked out.
So then that person has to make a cake.
So I hear that you are into Bundts.
- I Bundt.
- [Kelly] You Bundt, you Bundt.
- I have been known to Bundt.
- [Kelly] What's your favorite Bundt?
- Coca-Cola Bundt.
- Wait, what?
- [Laura] Yeah, Coca-Cola Bundt cake.
- You just mixed a soft drink with a cake.
- Yes, I sure did.
- [Kelly] I like that.
- But actually the people
who do it the best,
there's a bakery in New
York City called Baked.
They make a Coca-Cola Bundt
cake that is like no other.
- There's a lot of stores
here in LA named Baked.
(laughs)
- Different kind.
- But actually I brought one.
- You brought one! (gasps)
(audience cheers)
- I'm so excited, I've never heard of a--
- Oh, it's so good.
- Can we just, you know,
what's great about a Bundt?
It's so moist if it's done right.
- Oh, well wait.
- Okay, I'm just taking a butt.
Oh, they gave us one.
Oh wait, here's your--
Look we're passing to each other.
Okay wait, did you smell that?
Did you smell that?
You can't smell that, but I did.
Oh my God, this is gonna be good.
- Come on.
Come on.
- Oh my God.
- How about that?
- I love cake.
- Isn't it good?
- Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
- You're welcome.
- So I have to, I wanted to
get to that 'cause I smelled it
and that's why I cut to that after Ozark.
But I find this amazing
'cause you're one of the,
it's an amazing cast.
It's so well done.
But it's when I watch you, it's just like,
I know it's gonna sound like
such a tool thing to say,
but you're like one of the
like true really great actors.
- That's very kind.
(audience claps)
- And it's funny to me
because you had like
stagefright starting out.
- Oh yeah.
- I can never picture someone
as talented as you afraid.
- Oh, no, no, absolutely, absolutely.
- That's so--
- I mean, most of us are
nervous all the time.
You know, it's just human nature.
It's not a natural thing to do.
- I'm not in singing.
- Which is unbelievable.
- But in acting--
- I can't sing.
In my next life, I'm a
musical theater person
but no one wants to hear me sing.
- How did you get over that?
'Cause you're so good.
- I was able to go to
Juilliard for graduate school,
which was an amazing experience.
And during my third year
there, I completely fell apart.
And I developed a stage
fright that was just brutal.
It was awful.
- Did something happen?
- I did a play that just broke me.
And I just got scared and
I didn't wanna be there
and I almost dropped out of school.
- Oh my God.
- I got to point I was
like, this is too hard.
I can't do this, this is ridiculous.
And I had a wonderful teacher
by the name of John Sticks
who pulled me aside and he said,
"look, this is where you fail.
"This is where you have to fail."
- Oh, this is where you're
supposed to be learning.
- He's like, "this is where
you're supposed to fail
"is here, so good, congratulations."
He's like, "you must fail
in order to get better."
And it was a great lesson.
- Yeah.
- And like the big lesson always for me
is how to learn to sit in discomfort
and let things catch up
until you can move out of it.
- This is why I'm not an actor
'cause I avoid the (bleep)--
(audience laughs)
- But you know how to tell a story
so you can feel the narrative,
you can feel suspense within the music.
- I guess I've never thought
of it as like a song.
- The rhythm and the timing
and that you can feel when things are,
you know, you craft things in a way that
maybe you're not even
aware of, but it's similar.
- I don't know.
I think you just told me that I'm you.
So I'm gonna take that and (laughs)
I'm gonna filter that as I'm
talented, like Laura Linney.
Are you satisfied with the ending?
'Cause when there's such
a huge show like this
that hits in pop culture
that everybody loves.
Do you get nervous?
- I am, I wish it would go on forever.
So I wouldn't be satisfied with any ending
'cause I'm just gonna miss it so much.
But yes.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- [Laura] Yes, they did
a wonderful job with it.
- [Kelly] Not everybody
loves their show like that.
- I know we're very lucky.
It was a wonderful
experience for all of us.
We all loved it so I'm
just very sad it's ending.
- Do you think the fans
are gonna freak out
in a good way or bad way?
- I don't know.
I really, I have no idea.
But I think they'll freak out
- What a great tease!
Okay, I love that.
So the show is about what
people will do to survive.
So how do you think that you'd do
with the FBI and the cartel on you?
- Oh, I'm such a good girl.
- [Kelly] I am too.
- I'm so square.
- [Kelly] I'm not exciting.
I'm square I'm not.
I'm boring and square
- [Kelly] Me too.
- And always have been.
- Yeah, I like try and think
I'm really cool, I'm not.
- I got a speeding ticket a few years ago.
- [Kelly] I love that
that's your bad thing.
- That's my bad,
I got a speeding ticket and they came,
"Well, you know you're speeding?"
I was like, "Yeah, I am, I'm
so sorry, give me the ticket."
- Oh my God I'd do that.
- Yeah, I'm like you're right.
I didn't realize.
- Yeah.
You're probably gonna
give it to me anyway,
so let's just, you know.
- Let's just get it over with.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm so sorry, mea culpa.
- But that's your bad
thing though is speeding.
That's amazing.
- Yeah that's it
I'm boring, I'm so dull.
- (laughs) Freaking rebel.
All right, so we need another break.
- Okay, this is, can I do this now?
Your staff has been so kind.
- Thank you.
- [Laura] Your staff has been
really, really wonderful.
- I love my staff.
(audience clapping)
- And particularly I
wanna thank your IT guy.
- [Kelly] Tito?
- Tito.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who helped me sort of, with my phone
before we came out or so.
Is he around?
- Are you giving Tito a shout right now?
- [Laura] I'm giving Tito a shout out.
- Wait, Tito, Laura Linney just asked
for you to come down here.
Hey, what's up Tito?
(audience cheering)
There he is!
So Laura wanted to thank
you for making sure
that her Internet connection was--
- I just wanted to thank
you very, very much
for all of your help.
I know you came in and, you know,
get my phone secure and all of that.
- That's for you, Tito.
She's miced! (laughs)
- That's your mic.
- I think I know what's gonna happen next.
- So I just wanna say
from me and everyone here,
you've been Bundted.
- Yay!
(audience cheers)
That is right, Tito.
And a special shout out from Andra who,
along with everybody here,
thanks you for giving us all peace of mind
while we shop online when
we're supposed to be working
and Laura Linney just bunted you too.
That's amazing.
- Thank you, Andra.
- It's so amazing! (laughs)
I love that you were
like, "Ma'am?" (laughs)
Tito, she's got a mic on. (laughs)
You are so awesome for doing that.